Russland schickt weiter iranische
Drohnen in Großstädte schickte Raketen
in Wohngebiete zerstört Infrastruktur wo
es nur geht kurz verbrannte Erde als
neues Strategie Russland droht weiter
mit atomaren Schlägen und verdächtig die
Ukraine
schmutzige Bomben sogenannte schmutzige
Bomben zu bauen was er Putins eigenen
Plänen entsprechend dürfte was bedeutet
das alles und was kann der Westen tun
gegen diese neue Terror Strategie
politisch als auch militärisch das
fragen wir uns und diese Gäste
die
spd-vizepräsidentin des Europaparlaments
Katharina barley
Sergej lagutinski
Europaabgeordneter der Grünen geboren in
Astrachan
die russland-expertin Liana fix
Alice bota Journalistin bei der Zeit
und der Militärexperte Gustav gressel
sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit Illner
herzlich begrüßt Ausland verliert gerade
den Krieg am Boden also musste eine neue
Strategie
iranische Kamikaze Drohnen schlagen in
Kiew ein
[Musik]
Energieinfrastruktur ist das Ziel
Kollateralschäden übersetzt tote
Zivilisten in Wohnblocks sind
eingepreist
sie wollen die Infrastruktur zerstören
sie wollen dass die Menschen im Winter
frieren die Russen wollen eine
humanitäre Katastrophe in unserer
Heimatstadt
evakuieren russische Besatzer die
Einwohner
vermeintlich wegen eines ukrainischen
Angriffs vermutlich um die Stadt zu
überfluten
russische Soldaten sollen den Staudamm
karowa am Knieper vermiet haben
in nicolajew schlagen russische Raketen
in Wohngebiete ein
militärstrategisch nutzlos Tote und
Verletzte als Selbstzweck
und dann noch das jüngste falls Flat
narrativ aus Moskau schieb dem Gegner in
die Schuhe was Du selbst vorhast
Information wir haben konkrete
Informationen das ukrainische
Forschungslabore über Technologien
verfügen die Ihnen ermöglichen eine
schmutzige Bombe zu bauen
sagt der russische Außenminister Sergey
lewoff bei uns ist Gustav gressel einer
der beste Buchten Experten seit Monaten
Herr gressi die russische Armee greift
zivile Ziele greift Infrastruktur an
hemmungslos auf offene Bühne
Kriegsverbrechen warum
wenn es militärisch so wenig nutzt ist
das jetzt putinsplan
also der der Angriff auf zivile
Infrastruktur der hat zwar wenig
Auswirkungen auf den Verlauf der Front
und auf die Möglichkeiten der
ukrainischen Armee die Gegenoffensive
weiter anzutreiben weil ihre eigene
logistische Infrastruktur hat aber er
zerstört die ukrainische Wirtschaft
und das zielt im Grunde auf den Westen
auf die Unterstützung im Westen ab die
die Nachschub an Munition an
militärischen Gerät für die Ukraine aus
dem Westen ist die Lebenslinie der
ukrainischen Armee
der Krieg kostet die Ukraine zwischen 30
und 40 Millionen Euro pro Tag das Geld
muss auch irgendwo herkommen
desto weniger ukrainische Wirtschaft es
gibt und ohne Strom kann man wenig
produzieren
desto weniger kann die Ukraine das
selbst bezahlen desto mehr steigt wieder
die Abhängigkeit vom Westen das muss das
Geld muss bevorzugt werden es muss
kreditiert werden und es muss geschenkt
werden und im putinskalkül Plus
Inflation plus Energiekrise ist diese
Kosten Diskussion muss doch den Westen
dann irgendwann reichen genug sein und
er baut darauf dass dann im Westen
jemand auf dem Tisch schaut und sagt mir
jetzt jetzt
selence geht du musst jetzt die Annexion
einfach so akzeptieren oder wir stellen
das ein das ist so in kurz gesprochen
das Kalkül das hinter diesen Angriffen
steht und warum die systematische
Zerstörung von Infrastruktur die zwar
militärisch irrelevant ist auf die
ukrainische Wirtschaft hochrelevant ist
von Nutzen ist von Nutzen ist und sie
können uns auch erklären was es mit
dieser schmutzigen Bombe auf sich hat
das soll also eine konventionelle Bombe
sein mit radioaktiv verseuchten Material
und warum was soll dieses Spiel dass er
da spielt dem Westen zu unterstellen
mitzuhelfen dass die Ukraine das baut
und aber offensichtlich selber den Plan
zu haben also das die ganze
Anschuldigung ist ziemlich nebulös und
nachdem er die internationale ironen
Energiebehörde in der Ukraine auch
präsent ist und dort die LKWs regelmäßig
überwacht der völlig aus der Welt
gegriffen also jeder der die
inspektionsregimes kennt der weiß dass
das Schwachsinn ist aber es ist
natürlich die die Furcht vor der
nuklearen Katastrophe die spielen in den
Öffentlichkeiten leider haben unsere
Politiker auf beiden Seiten des
Atlantiks auch dazu beigetragen durch
das ständige betonen beiden mit seiner
Rede wir sind in einer Situation wieder
Kubakrise auch Scholz der waren vor dem
dritten Weltkrieg haben leider dazu
beigetragen dass Putin sieht dass das
aufgegriffen wird dass diese Furcht vor
den nuklearen Katastrophe resoniert in
auch in den politischen Köpfen und
deshalb wird sie bedient und natürlich
ist die Art und Weise wie sie das machen
wie sie Fotos fälschen wie sie
irgendwelche irgendwas zusammenzimmern
auf dem Niveau von zwölfjährigen die
sich was googeln nicht besonders nicht
besonders ausgeklügelt aber Rauchmelder
als vermeintlicher Beweis vorgezeigt
worden darüber lacht natürlich dann auch
die Welt ist es ihm egal dass das
lächerliche Vorwürfe sind zu einem
gewissen
was die interne Kommunikation angeht ist
ja legal weil im russischen Fernsehen
selber natürlich dann niemand Auftritten
sagt dass es Mumpitz sondern da wird es
sozusagen eingespeist in die übliche
Produktion
dass die Außenwirkung dass man sich da
lächerlich macht das ja wird im
hoffentlich irgendwann einmal jemand
sagen
wir haben Liana fix bei uns aus Europa
und Russland Expertin eines
amerikanischen Think Tanks sie haben in
einem Interview Frau fix gesagt dass das
eine der bedrohlichsten Phasen des
Krieges ist eine der gefährlichsten in
die wir gerade kommen können Sie
erklären warum ist das so gefährlich
es ist so gefährlich weil wir gerade
eine Strategie der Eskalation aus einer
Position der Schwäche sehen also was
Putin versucht ist dass er die Front die
er im Osten hat er kann diese Front
nicht stabilisieren nicht mit den
massenmobilisierungen die ihr durchführt
und deswegen versucht er durch diese
Eskalation einen Punkt zu erreichen an
dem die westlichen Unterstützer der
Ukraine sagen Stopp jetzt das wird uns
zu gefährlich wir müssen diesen Kampf
beenden und alles deutet darauf hin dass
das eine psychologische Operation ist
die geführt wird gegen westliche
Gesellschaften und trotzdem ist es
natürlich nicht hundert Prozent
auszuschließen das parallel zu dieser
psychologischen Operation auch der Boden
vorbereitet wird für eine mögliche
weitere Eskalation das heißt wir haben
gesehen dass mit der Massenmobilisierung
mit der Annexion die Idee dass der
russische Präsident bereit sein wird für
Verhandlungen wenn er weit genug
zurückgedrängt ist im Krieg nicht mehr
funktioniert er hat das Tor für
Verhandlungen selbst geschlossen und das
macht es eben so gefährlich dass sich
alle Optionen offen hält und dass die
Ukraine zwar weiterkämpft aber immer
diese Frage darüber schwebt was sind
jetzt eigentlich genau die roten Linien
und weiß der russische Präsident
eigentlich selbst was seine roten Linien
sind hält er sich an die nuklear
Doktrinen die ganz klar besagt dass
Russland nur Nuklearwaffen einsetzt wenn
seine Existenz bedroht ist oder kommt er
irgendwann an einem Punkt wo er doch mit
dem Gedanken spielt ich glaube im Moment
ist es eine psychologische Operation
völlig auszuschließen ist es jedoch
nicht und das ist auch der Grund für die
Nervosität
und er bietet ja nun heute auch wieder
absurderweise Gespräche an dazu kommen
wir noch erstmal freuen wir uns auch
über die Anwesenheit von Sergej
lagodinski Herr lagodinski sie sind in
der Sowjetunion geboren muss man sagen
1975 in astrachern das ist heute Süd
Russland
und sie sind in Deutschland aufgewachsen
Sitzen für die Grünen im Europaparlament
sie waren ausgerechnet an diesem 9
oktober in Kiew als zum ersten Mal diese
Drohnenangriffe stattfanden
iranischer Bauart und haben was dabei
erlebt wie sind die Ukrainer mit dieser
Situation umgegangen ich bin auf
Einladung des Justizministeriums
angekommen gerade justa an diesem Tag
auch um über die Strafverfolgung der
Verbrechen der russischen Seite zu
sprechen wir können wir da behilflich
sein und ausgerechnet dann sind die
Angriffe gestartet ich habe
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer erlebt als
absolut gefasst das sind sehr viele
junge Leute die auch sehr behilflich
waren auch im Bunker sie wussten schon
was zu tun ist und haben es in vielen
auch ausländischen Gästen da geholfen
eine Entschlossenheit und allen auf eine
Art und Weise eine Entspannung und
Entspanntheit die ich nur bewundern kann
und das ist natürlich
erst im Nachhinein habe ich mit einigen
gesprochen die mit uns unterwegs waren
und an diesen Stellen wurden ein paar
Minuten später Menschen umgebracht und
erst später ist uns und auch den
ukrainischen Freunden klar geworden was
für ein Glück wir hatten dass wir dem
auch entwischt sind für mich persönlich
war das wieder eine Bestätigung dass
auch Waffenlieferungen für uns eine
humanitäre Pflicht ist wir retten
Menschenleben wenn wir das tun
wir freuen uns über all diese Butter bei
uns in dieser Sendung arbeitet für die
Zeit ursprünglich aus Polen und für den
Osten über Polen über Moskau und
Warschau viel berichtend für die Zeit
Frau Butter sie haben natürlich mit uns
gemeinsam jetzt auch das Gefühl okay da
versucht diese russische Diktator den
Willen eines Volkes zu brechen mit einer
neuen Strategie sich zu verteidigen
diesen Willen zu sprechen zu sprechen
glauben Sie dass es ihm gelingt das
hatte ich wirklich für ausgeschlossen
das ist doch ein wichtiger Aspekt was
die Drohnen angeht was Herr Kresse eben
angesprochen hat es gibt nicht nur darum
Infrastruktur zu zerstören dafür zu
sorgen dass die Leute frieren es kann im
Winter bis zum -20°c werden dass die
Leute kein Wasser haben können Strom ich
sprach gerade gestern mit ukrainischen
Journalisten die sagten ab 18 Uhr
sitzen wir im Dunkeln weil wir
angehalten werden im ernst genommen
aber es geht eben auch darum wirklich
die Bevölkerung zu terrorisieren dafür
zu sorgen dass man sich nirgends sicher
fühlen kann nicht in der kleinen
Nebenstraße nicht in dem kleinen Café
die sind drohen schießen sie können
eigentlich jedes Ziel treffen und und
das sind eben auch zivile Ziele
und trotzdem die diese Entschiedenheit
von der sie gerade gesprochen haben die
belegen sogar Umfragen es gab Umfragen
in der Ukraine was die Verhandlung
angeht die Bereitschaft auf ein
vergiftetes Verhandlungsangebot von
Russland einzugehen und diese Umfragen
sind atemberaubend eindeutig selbst im
Osten des Landes der Landteile ja am
meisten bislang zu leiden hatte den
Osten und der Süden unter diesem Krieg
war die die absolute Mehrheit
dagegen ein solches vergiftetes
Verhandlungsangebot anzunehmen und das
ist schon sehr bemerkenswert und zeigt
eben auch den Unterschied zwischen
Ukraine und Russland Russland
entscheidet ein Mann in der Ukraine hat
Präsident selenski Verantwortung
gegenüber den Menschen aber eben auch
gegenüber Wählerinnen und Wählern das
heißt wenn er sich auf ein Kompromiss
einlässt der sein Land noch mehr schadet
als der Krieg ist Menschen tut dann kann
es enorme politische Kosten haben er
kann aus dem Amt enthoben werden und wer
weiß wer dann kommt also er hat eine
Verantwortung
man verhandeln darf mit Putin in dieser
jetzigen Situation das ist ein Dekret
dass ich vor allem als ein
innenpolitisches Signal verstehe weiß
nicht ich halte es nicht für besonders
hilfreich es richtet sich aber weniger
an an das Außen sondern vielmehr an die
eigene Wählerinnen und Wähler und an die
Ukrainern zu zeigen wir sind hier in
einer also wir halten diese Position
Katharina barley ist bei uns die
Vizepräsidentin des Europäischen
Parlamentes formalisie haben und das
muss man ja jetzt auch erstmal verstehen
sie haben politisch natürlich damit
umzugehen dass dieser Wladimir Putin
eben uns auch immer wieder mit neuen
Strategien mit noch größerer Brutalität
mit noch größerer Vernichtung überrascht
wie genauso mit neuen taktischen Zügen
glauben sie und wann denken Sie haben
wir eine Antwort darauf haben wir auch
eine
politische aber auch erstmal eine
militärische Antwort darauf kann es die
geben außer die Ukraine weiter massiv zu
unterstützen
nun ich glaube die Tatsache dass
Wladimir Putin seine Taktik jetzt
mehrfach geändert hat zeigt ja dass die
Europäische Union durchaus eine Antwort
gefunden hat also ich fand das damals
überraschend und auch beeindruckend wie
schnell die EU reagiert hat innerhalb
von drei Tagen das muss man sich noch
mal vor Augen führen von die Sanktionen
auf den Weg gebracht die
Hilfspakete und Waffenlieferungen bzw
die Unterstützung die finanzielle
Unterstützung von Waffenlieferung in der
EU innerhalb von drei Tagen also ich
finde das war eine sehr sehr
beeindruckende klare deutliche Antwort
an Putin die er mit Sicherheit nicht
erwartet hat auch die Geschlossenheit
der EU hat er nicht erwartet und die
Sanktionen insbesondere haben ja
durchaus Wirkungen gezeigt jetzt
sprechen sie schon wieder über die
Sanktionen vorbei aber ich fragte ja
nach der Situation jetzt ist man jetzt
nicht erst mal ziemlich hilflos muss man
nicht jetzt erstmal dann auch sehr
schnell in Abstimmung in den
europäischen Ländern erreichen um
festzulegen wie probieren wir darauf wie
reagieren wir darauf politisch wie
reagieren wir darauf militärisch das
andere was sie beschrieben ist
Monate her
ja wobei wir müssen natürlich
weitermachen den Druck auch auf die
russische Wirtschaft aufrecht zu
erhalten die die Möglichkeit für putinen
Nachschub zu organisieren auch
technische Nachschub für sein Militär
das müssen wir natürlich weiter
erschweren aber es stimmt durch diese
veränderte Strategie jetzt auf die
Infrastruktur zu gehen wird natürlich
einiges deutlich schwieriger man kann
die Ziele die die zivile Infrastruktur
nicht in dem Maße schützen wie man
einzelne militärische Objekte schützen
kann da auch noch mal helfen von dem
Militärexperten Herr kressel was würden
Sie denn sagen was kann man jetzt tun
was kann man gegen diese Drohnenangriffe
tun was kann man gegen Sabotage tun was
kann man diese gegen die general
mobilbaren Teil mobil machen tun die das
Russland ja weiter betreibt das ist ja
nicht vorbei gegen alle möglichen
luftkriegsmittel hat man
schon begonnen fliegerapfelsysteme zu
liefern so so sehr ich die deutsche
Bundesregierung dafür kritisiere dass
sie nichts tut hat sie auf diesem Feld
mal auch rechtzeitig gehandelt weil er
im Mai schon beschlossen wurde irrest
Tee zu liefern und diese Geräte brauchen
das natürlich besonders gegen
Marschflugkörper gegen
es kann da ähnliche Geräte wirkt gegen
Drohnen ist es so dass zum Beispiel die
die einfache Modifikation von von
relativ primitiven aus den 50er Jahren
sowohl im Westen als auch im Osten
verhandeln im Flieger abwehrkanonen mit
mit elektrischen Steuerungssystemen dass
man sie einen Radar koppeln kann relativ
viel bewirken kann
aber das zweite Problem ist dass die
Ukraine militärisch hat ist dass die die
Munition vor allen Dingen für Geräte
östlicher Bauart für Artillerie
östlicher Ort für panzeröstliche baut
knapp wird dass die Ersatzteile knapp
werden es gab eine Zeit aber jede dritte
ukrainische Granate aus Bulgarien aber
die Lager sind dort auch leer die
munitionsproduktion das kann der der
militärische Widerstand der Ukraine kann
nicht an der tschechisch polnisch
bulgarischen munitionsproduktion liegen
das ist völlig irrw witzig und und da
braucht es da unbedingt eine da braucht
es eine eine koordinierte Politik das
Problem ist das was das Rammstein Format
ist jetzt nicht geliefert hat war eine
eine Koordinierung zwischen Industrie
und betreiberstaaten über über alle
europäischen Staaten hinwegzuschauen
welches Gerät können wir zusammen Polen
nicht jeder Staat findet irgendwo in der
verstauten Garage noch zwei Geräte von
XY
wie können wir doch eine gemeinsame
Beschaffung dafür sorgen dass die
Nachbeschaffung dieser Geräte durch die
Industrie auch in dem Zeitraum und in
der Stückzahl auch kommt die wir
brauchen wenn man die
kampfpanzergeschichte ansehen es gibt
für den Leopard zwei drei
Produktionsstraßen in Europa und
produzieren alle mit Handbremse bzw gar
nicht weil der stadtbedarf der
europäische Gesamtbedarf an diesen
Geräten nicht feststellen obwohl es
x-staaten gibt die schon darüber
nachdenken zu modernisieren neue Geräte
zu kaufen und so weiter das sind viel zu
viel politische Blockaden drin da ist
viel zu viel Unentschlossenheit drin
nach acht Monaten des Krieges und das
können wir uns nicht lang leisten wir
sind ja vielleicht nur noch ergänzen es
gibt ja durchaus auch Luft nach oben bei
der europäischen Reaktion also es gibt
sowohl bei der finanziellen
Unterstützung für die Ukraine gibt es
Kritik aus Kiew dass die versprochenen
von den versprochenen neun Milliarden
sechs Milliarden immer noch nicht
ausgezahlt sind die USA Zahlen in nicht
den Krediten sondern sie geben ihr Geld
sozusagen direkt an die Ukraine das ist
ein weiterer Kritikpunkt den man auch in
Washington hört dass die gut zu langsam
ist bei den Auszahlungen an die Ukraine
die einen monatlichen Bedarf hat der um
die drei bis vier Billionen Dollar ist
das ist einfach viel Geld was man sich
jetzt aufteilt zwischen den USA und
Europa und der andere Kritikpunkt ist
natürlich schon das ist eine Lücke gibt
zwischen den militärischen
Unterstützungsleistungen der
europäischen Länder der EU und den USA
und leider ist es so natürlich sind
solche Analysen immer nur ein
Momentaufnahme aber man sieht schon dass
in den letzten Monaten die Lücke
gewachsen ist und die USA immer weiter
nach vorne gegangen sind und es immer
ein immer einen größeren Abstand gibt
von den USA zu den Unterstützung aus der
EU und das stellt natürlich langfristig
die Frage kann das denn sein dass die
USA mehr investieren in diesen Krieg als
es die Europäer investieren und das ist
natürlich auch eine Frage die an
Deutschland gestellt sind nicht nur bei
der Linken wir sind jetzt schon wieder
in den Reaktionen Europas ich würde
gerne einmal noch eine Sekunde bei
dieser neuen Situation bleiben es wird
Frau fix ja auch gedroht seitens der
Russen einen großen Staudamm zu
Bomben zu zerstören oder ihn eben zu
vermieden um eine riesige Region von
Fluten der sagt ein Kollege von ihnen
car das hätte eine so katastrophale
Wirkung dass man es mit einer taktischen
Atomrakete vergleichen könnte weil es
einen so massiven Schaden anrichtet was
tut man gegen und das ist jetzt noch mal
eine echte Frage was ist neu was tut man
gegen so massive Sabotageakte und
Terrorakte der Russen also zum einen
würde ich jetzt nicht ein Panzer also
nee absolut aber zum einen würde so eine
Sprengung natürlich hätte den Vorteil
für Russland das ist der Ukraine
erschweren würde durch über so viel
Wasser sozusagen Russland weiter
zurückzudrängen es würde aber auch die
Wasserversorgung der Krim erschweren
deswegen muss man sehen ob das wirklich
sozusagen umgesetzt wird aber was die
Ukraine gemacht hat und was sie sehr
intelligent gemacht hat ist fort
vorgeschlagen dass Beobachter an diesen
Damm geschickt werden internationale
Beobachter und damit das Modell des
ukrainischen Atomkraftwerks wo die
international Atomenergiebehörde vor Ort
ist sozusagen repliziert wird wenn
Russland sagt die Ukraine will diesen
bringen dann kann man sie damit
sozusagen am schlawittchen packen und
sagen gut wenn ihr die Sorge habt dann
stimmt doch internationalen Beobachtern
zu und das ist etwas was ein sinnvoller
Vorschlag ist und wo man Russland unter
Druck mitsetzen kann denn das auch
überhaupt ist dann schicken wir
internationale Beobachter dahin die das
klären können auch die Frage an Sie noch
mal Herr gresse was ist neu neu ist über
solche Dinge auch in aller
Öffentlichkeit natürlich zu reden
Spekulationen
Ängste Sorgen zu schüren aber auch immer
wieder Belege dafür zu haben auch dass
die Russen eben einen Teil dieses
Staudamms vermiet haben sollen auch an
Sie die Frage was tut man dagegen und
wie lange würde es brauchen der
Öffentlichkeit nachzuweisen das ist die
Ukraine eben nicht wahr sondern dass es
die Russen waren also ein Staudamm ist
ein enorm massives Bauwerk das ist nicht
so wie ein James Bond Filmen dass da das
Superheld kommt und denn den explosiv
Kaugummi irgendwo ankleben nur fliegt
alles in die Luft wenn er daraus geht
und aus seiner Uhr dreht sondern da
brauche sich enorme Mitteln an an
Sprengmitteln um das in Luft zu jagen
ich brauche auch die teilkenntnis über
den Damm ich muss diese Sprengmittel
verdämmen ich muss in die Staumauer
eintragen ich brauche also Zugang zum
Gebäude zu den wartungstunneln etc um
das hoch zu jagen deshalb ist schon mal
die erste Sache um sowas vorzubereiten
brauche ich Stunden um am dann zu Werken
wenn eine Partei die diesen Damm nicht
kontrolliert und dort nicht die Zeit hat
stundenlang rumzuwirken kann den
technisch nicht in die Luft jagen das
geht nicht und wir halten das also für
illusorisch das überhaupt zu versuchen
und man kann es versuchen wenn man sich
bei wenn man sich da länger darauf
vorbereitet aber dann ist natürlich die
Verantwortung klar in der Hand jeder
Partei die diesen Damen kontrolliert das
sind zurzeit die Streitkräfte der
Russischen Föderation und
wenn die Ukraine mit ihrer gegen
Offensive weiterkommen und im Zuge der
Rück eines dieser Damm gesprengt wird
dann weiß man wer ihn dort gesprengt hat
weil eben das nicht in fünf Minuten geht
so so ein Ding mit mit Sprengstoff
aufzubereiten und und in die Luft zu
jagen also das
und dann kann man natürlich im weiteren
Verlauf kann man gerichtliche
Untersuchungen haben setzen die die
Ursache dann auch genau feststellen das
dauert genauso wie Nord Stream
Sprengungen natürlich Ewigkeit lange
aber ja diesen Nachweis zu erbringen wir
wollen Frau Butter noch mal fragen ob
dieser Situation wie groß ist die Gefahr
das tatsächlich auch die Reaktion der
NATO Länder eine unterschiedliche sein
wird weil sich manche eben das klang
schon an beeindruckt fühlen weil manche
sagen oh das wird jetzt aber alles doch
eine sehr lange Reise die ihr nicht
gebucht haben wie sehr denken sie das
eben auch die NATO-Länder unter sich
dass die Europäer unter sich darüber in
Streit geraten werden es gibt ja zum
einen die Türkei als ein nateland das
gerade von Vladimir Putin ja sehr gelobt
worden ist in seiner Rede die aber eine
ganz spannende Rolle einnimmt also indem
sie sich immer wieder für
örtlich
begrenzte Deals als Verhandler anbietet
also zum Beispiel dieser Getreide Deal
da war Erdogan involviert gleichzeitig
fährt man Gespräche auf dem ukrainischen
Seite ich sehe nicht so sehr die
Befürchtung dass es eine Spaltung der
NATO gibt denn NATO ist ja in diesem
Sinne in diesem Krieg nicht involviert
es sind Länder die eben bilateral die
Ukraine unterstützen und es ist die EU
die die Ukraine unterstützt die Gefahr
sehe ich eher bei der Spaltung der EU
also Ungarn ist beispielsweise ein Land
in dem es wahrscheinlich mit der Zeit
immer schwieriger wird
davon zu überzeugen dass der Kurs der EU
weiterhin gehalten wird aber auch
hierzulande wird es immer schwieriger
werden dieser Krieg wird dauern und die
Kosten sind enorm für die Ukraine aber
auch für all jene wie sie ihm
unterstützen
es gibt hierzulande ist es gibt eine es
gibt soziale angespannte Situationen für
nicht wenige Menschen und das erzeugt
enormen Druck auf die auf die Parteien
ist dann zeugt ein enormen Druck auf die
Politik doch irgendetwas zu tun dann
kommen wir zu den Reaktionen und auch
vor allen Dingen zu den deutschen
Reaktionen seit neun Monaten Wert nun
dieser Krieg schon und es gibt einen
fast möchte man sagen bekanntenstreit
auch innerhalb der
es brodelt in Deutschland
immer wieder hält Putin das Preisschild
hoch
[Musik]
Waffen zu liefern ist die Entscheidung
der Leute die an die Macht gekommen sind
in Deutschland sie müssen für sich
klären was wichtiger ist das Erfüllen
von vermeintlichen Verpflichtungen
gegenüber Alliierten oder das Absichern
der Interessen ihres eigenen Volkes
erfolgreicher als auf dem Schlachtfeld
gedeiht der Spaltpilz des Kreml nicht
AFD nicht linke es spricht der
Fraktionschef der Kanzlerpartei die
letzten Meinungsumfragen 60 Prozent die
mehr diplomatische Initiativen wollen
und ich denke mal das ist auch an die
Adresse der Außenministerin gesagt
worden leichtfertige Sprüche naja jetzt
verhandelt doch endlich mal es kommt ja
nicht auf jeden Fall der Ukraine so
dringend an
wie geschlossen ist der Westen noch den
russischen vormar stoppen ist das eine
aber wie stoppt man Putins Politik der
verbrannten Erde
mittendrin der Kanzler der stemmt sich
gegen die Fliehkraft
Solidarität mit der Ukraine und
Solidarität mit den EU-Partnern
jetzt geht's los Frau barley wir
zitierten den Fraktionschef der SPD Rolf
Mütze nicht der findet dass Diplomatie
die wichtigste deutsche Disziplin sei
und die Außenministerin die
bundesaußenministerin da endlich auf die
Bühne treten soll wie berechtigt ist
seine Forderung in ihren Augen also ich
habe mich natürlich nach dieser Äußerung
auch noch mal mit Berlin rückekoppelt
und Anruf
wir hatten wir haben ständige ständige
Gesprächskanäle und
jedenfalls ist es mir so kommuniziert
worden dass das durchaus breiter gemeint
ist als es hier jetzt sozusagen gemünzt
wurde und auch in der Politik gemünzt
wurde nämlich das ist ja auch noch
Diplomatie rund um die Parteien Russland
Ukraine gibt es gibt auch noch andere
mit denen man reden muss das sind
insbesondere
Staaten die in diesem Konflikt eine
Rolle spielen zum Beispiel also ganz und
Balance zwischen dem
Selbstverteidigungsrecht der Ukraine und
diplomatischen Initiativen muss endlich
hergestellt werden also das hat jetzt
weniger mit irgendwas anderem zu tun da
geht es um diesen Konflikt das ist die
Forderung von Rolf Mütze nicht also die
die Position die wir da haben ist total
klar
die ist das eine diplomatische Bemühung
nur dann Sinn macht wenn es eine wenn es
eine Aussicht darauf gibt dass es auch
eine Lösung gibt die die Ukraine
akzeptieren kann und die gibt es derzeit
nicht das heißt aber nicht wie gesagt
dass man in dem Umfeld dass wir haben
China spielt eine große Rolle Indien
spielt eine große Rolle dass man diese
Gespräche führen muss führen muss wir
sind mehr lagodinski bei den Grünen sie
haben eine sagen um wobende Rede auf dem
grünen Parteitag gehalten und haben
gesagt die Ukraine können sich nicht mit
Sonnenblumen verteidigen glauben sie
dass Annalena baerbock solche Hinweise
braucht von Rolf Mütze nicht für ihre
Arbeit
das glaube ich nicht und vor allem finde
ich dass wir wirklich ernsthafte
Gespräche führen müssen auch wir unter
uns wie wir eine führende Partei die
Kanzlerpartei
dazu bringen eine einheitliche klare
Linie zu fahren denn dieses hin und her
und ständige Signale die etwas
widersprüchlich sind sie beschädigen
nicht nur diese Koalition sie
beschädigen auch die Europäische Union
wir sind in Brüssel als Deutschland muss
man sagen unten durch wenn wir schauen
darauf wie die osteuropäischen die
mitteleuropäischen Staaten über uns
reden wir haben jetzt ein Problem mit
Frankreich und das kommt dadurch dass
die Signale so widersprüchlich sind und
dass wir immer noch nicht begriffen
haben diese EU wir haben darüber
gesprochen die EU muss zusammengehalten
werden das ist ja nicht ein abstraktes
Konstrukt sondern da sind
führungs-führung die wir brauchen und
diese krisenführung vermisse ich leider
aus von der höchsten Stelle in
in unserem Land die SPD in ihren Augen
ein ist die SPD die Kanzler tragende
Partei in ihren Augen ein verlässlicher
Partner an der Seite der Ukraine in
diesem Kampf gegen Russland
selbstverständlich wer machen doch
vieles ja und gerade deswegen ist das
doch so bitter wenn solche Äußerungen
kommen und dann an diesem klaren Kurs
denn diese Regierung doch führt zweifeln
lassen denn viele Menschen die von
außerhalb das sehen sie verstehen nicht
dass Deutschland so viel zahlt das auch
im Kanzleramt sehr viele Menschen viel
dafür tun damit wir fest an der Seite
der Ukraine stehen aber es entsteht der
Eindruck dass die Partei die
Kanzlerpartei nicht klar ist
in dieser nach dieser Zeitenwende denn
die zeitenwände ist nicht nur 100
Milliarden die zeitenwände ist ein neues
Denken wir sind in einem absolut neuen
schwierigen wir sind in der schwersten
Krise geostrategischen Krise dieses
Kontinent und hier brauchen wir Klarheit
die auch für andere Länder gelten muss
und auch für helfen in Hamburg
oder andere Entscheidungen solche Art
wir müssen geostrategisch klar denken
und unabhängig und Abhängigkeiten
vermeiden die wir vermeiden können ich
glaube das Problem ist tatsächlich nicht
dass Deutschland nicht in zuverlässiger
Partner ist und sozusagen da auch noch
mal die Perspektive aus Washington auf
Deutschland mitzubringen sondern das
Problem ist dass Deutschland nicht
bereit ist eine Führungsrolle in diesem
Krieg einzunehmen die USA haben seit dem
Beginn des Krieges eine übergroße
Führungsrolle eingenommen und die
Europäer lehnen sich ein bisschen zurück
mit dem Gefühl das ist sicherer ist im
Windschatten der USA zu agieren und das
sehen wir auch bei Deutschland am
Beispiel zum Beispiel der
leopard-kampfpanzerlieferungen diese
ewige Sage in der die heiße Kartoffel
hin und hergeworfen wird in Berlin wird
gesagt dass wir ja schon genau das ist
Washington stimmt da nicht zu aber das
ist genauso ein Beispiel dafür wo man
sich eine deutsche Führung wünschen
würde
äh die sozusagen voran geht in Europa wo
sich auch die USA diese deutsche Führung
wünschen würde aber wo genau dafür diese
Bereitschaft momentan nicht besteht Frau
bota vielleicht auch noch mal mit dem
Blick auf Osteuropa und Stichwort das
war ja ihr Gedanke die Spaltung Europas
ist im Grunde ja da mit Händen zu
greifen was müsste diese Bundesregierung
denn tun mal einmal andersrum gefragt um
die Osteuropäer nicht mehr so schlecht
und so misstrauisch auf Deutschland
schauen zu lassen also ganz so weit
würde ich jetzt nicht gehen dass ich
jetzt schon von einer Spaltung sprechen
würde ich sehe nur eben die Gefahr und
tatsächlich ist es bemerkenswert wie
Herr Scholz in Baltikum in Polen aber
auch in Finnland wahrgenommen wird und
es Schaden ist da tatsächlich groß und
ich habe den anderen Mann beobachtet
einerseits wie die Sozialdemokraten ihre
eigene Politik und Geschichte
aufarbeiten was wichtig ist
nach außen transportiert sich das
natürlich nicht also Herr klingt bei
hatte eine Rede gehalten der über die
Fehler gesprochen hat die man in der
russland-politik gemacht hat
im Baltikum denkt man die SPD ist sehr
stolz und nimmt eben diese Nuancierung
verständlicherweise auch nicht wahr und
Herr Scholze mag es tatsächlich nicht
hier klar zu kommunizieren ich Gehalte
tatsächlich das größte Problem als eines
der Kommunikation dieses zaghafte die
ist ein bisschen unverbindliche man
macht's am Ende immer ein bisschen zu
spät immer ein bisschen zu wenig und ihm
immer so ein bisschen für klausuliert
und
in Estland in Litauen in Lettland in
Polen
hat man ihm dieses Gefühl wir leben mit
diesen russischen Nachbarn schon viele
Jahre wir haben euch so viele Jahre
gewarnt vor der Gas Abhängigkeit von
Nord Stream 2 es ist nie ernst genommen
worden und tatsächlich was macht jetzt
das Kanzleramt entscheidet sich dafür in
Hamburg eben die Chinesen mit einer
Mindestbeteiligung an einem Terminal
teilhaben zu lassen und man hat das
Gefühl so
der hier ist tatsächlich die große Linie
nicht verstanden worden dass ein Jahr
2022 es nicht eine Option sein sollte
dass sich ein Staat
bei dem man Misstrauen angemessen ist an
einer solchen Infrastruktur beteiligt
also versuchen wir nicht gleich bei
China zu landen sondern sind jetzt
erstmal bei Frau barley Frau Bale sie
haben und dann müssen wir auch gar nicht
Olaf Scholz zitieren oder uns gleich mit
Lars Klingbeil befassen sie haben letzte
Woche noch der taz der Tageszeitung ein
Interview gegeben und haben gesagt
Deutschlands Stärken sind Diplomatie
Krisenprävention soft power da müssen
wir eine Führungsrolle Spielen nicht
beim Militär ich glaube Germany has Acts
according to it history Deutschland muss
gemäß seiner Geschichte handeln
sehen sie das wirklich so also das ist
der zweite Teil eine Ausführung weil ich
hatte einen baltischen Kollegen einen
litauischen Kollegen mit dem ich darüber
gesprochen habe und der ganz im
Gegensatz zu dem was sie gerade gesagt
haben sehr wohl sagte wir sehen das wir
sehen dass ihr einen Deutschland
Riesenschritte macht wir sehen woher ihr
kommt das für euch dieses Verhältnis zu
Russland ein völlig anderes ist als für
jeden anderen Staat in dieser
Europäischen Union das eher eine
Verantwortung habt die euch bisher eine
gewisse
Herangehensweise an Russland auferlegt
hat und dass ihr von der erstmal weg
kommen müsst dass das eine historische
Leistung ist das zu tun so wird dort die
zeitenwände auch gesehen Christine
Lamprecht
[Musik]
coding to it size daher kommt dieses
Zitat also jetzt müssen wir aber genau
jetzt
agieren und müssten sagen jetzt müsst
ihr militärisch die die Führung
übernehmen was wir ja wenn wir unsere
militärischen Möglichkeiten anschauen im
Vergleich zu unserer Größe sind die ja
deutlich kleiner als jetzt
beispielsweise in Frankreich oder UK was
nicht mehr zur EU gehört aber auch zu
Europa so und das ist jetzt nun der
Punkt wo ich gesagt habe das sagt ihr
jetzt und vielen anderen Punkten wenn
wir dann aber nach unserer Größe handeln
dann kommt ganz schnell gerade auch aus
Polen die Reaktion ups jetzt kommt
wieder das Deutschland was uns erklären
will
wie es jetzt bei uns zu laufen aber es
gibt viele Staaten die sich führen
wünschen die sich auch militärische
Führung wünschen Frau barley die sagen
wir grassel schilderte in der
ramsteingruppe die ist ja jetzt gar
nicht NATO geführt sondern sie ist eben
von den US-Amerikanern in Ramstein
geführt bräuchte es tatsächlich das
Engagement der deutschen und das mal
ermöglichen eines gemeinsamen Projektes
um der Ukraine die Leopard zu kommen
aber dann brauchen wir militärische
Führung Frau Lamprecht sagt das sie sagt
Deutschland hat die Größe die
geographische Kraft und die
Wirtschaftskraft kurz das Gewicht und
das macht uns zu einer Führungsmacht
auch im militärischen sagen sie das
Gegenteil einer aber doch nicht alleine
und das war immer der Punkt von Olaf
Scholz zu sagen wir gehen nicht alleine
voran auch nicht bei den
Panzerlieferungen es gibt keine andere
wollte Panzer liefern und es wurde aus
Deutschland im Prinzip unterbunden also
wenn es wurde immer gesagt wenn wir das
gemeinsam machen können vor allen Dingen
mit Frankreich mit USA und mit und mit
UK dann gehen wir diesen Weg gemeinsam
und das ist eben der Punkt wir sind
natürlich sind wir eine Führungsmacht
aber wir sind nicht die
führungsmiliterien
die sich jetzt sozusagen im wahrsten
Sinne des Wortes an die Speerspitze der
Bewegung aber das geht nicht
der französische kampfpassen ist seit
2010 nicht mehr Produktion jeder
leclercte an die Ukraine geliefert
werden würde wenn es doch in dem
reservepool noch welche gibt würde das
Betreiben der bestehenden Kampf von zur
Flotte in Frankreich in existenzgefahr
bringen dasselbe gilt für den britischen
Challenger es kann keine
deutsch-französisch britische
panzerinitiative geben der amerikanische
Abrams da wird jetzt erst übrigens mit
dem ersten Betreiber in Europa überhaupt
die logistische Infrastruktur aufgebaut
um das liefern zu können Leopard wird in
Polen gewartet es gibt dort
Infrastruktur die Techniker die heilen
das Personal polnische Firmen sind in
einer Modernisierung des Leopard 2 mit
integriert dass das in hanebüchernde
Ausreden es gibt in Europa den Leopard 2
und man muss ja mittlerweile sagen
leider leider hat sich Europa auf einen
deutschen Kampfpanzer geeignet denn
jetzt ist er ein Hindernis jetzt ist ein
Risiko Weiler deutsches und das ist eine
normale Problem das betrifft nicht nur
den Krieg jetzt in der Ukraine und
Hilfeleistung das betrifft das
langfristige Vertrauen in gemeinsamer
europäische rüstungs- und
beschaffungsprojekte aber da haben wir
doch eine Lösung auch vorgeschlagen wir
haben ja in der Resolution des
Europäischen Parlaments
ihren Vorschlag unter anderem auch
übernommen wir sollen einen Pool von an
Leopard Panzern etablieren und dadurch
diese Europäisierung erreichen aber dann
eben etwas tun weil wir über es Zeit
nehmen Ermöglicher quasi dieses Pools 12
europäische Länder 2000 Panzer hätten
wir insgesamt also und das ist der Punkt
wir verzetteln uns in diesen
Kleinigkeiten und für uns ist
zeitenwände schon zwei Prozent mehr in
unserem Haushalt für die ukraineren und
Ukrainer ist Zeitenwende erst dann wenn
sie wenn aufgehört wird sie zu morden
und zu vergewaltigen das ist die Zeiten
drin
zu liefern also die das System was sie
was sie vorhin erwähnt die haben das
genau
in Erinnerung habe eins was noch nicht
mal die Bundeswehr selbst hat derzeit
und das ist schon also das modernste was
es im Grunde genommen gibt und das wird
an die Ukraine geliefert man kann ja
wöchentlich gucken was alles an die
Ukraine geliefert wird
zurzeit auch die Fähigkeit der
Ukrainerinnen und erkennen die besetzten
Gebiete zu befreien weil das was dort
passiert sind die schwersten
Menschenrechtsverbrechen und das können
sie nur mit Kampfpanzern tun also sie
verpassen gerade weil wir hadern sie
verpassen gerade hadern sie verpassen
die strategischen Momente die sie nutzen
könnten um das territoren zu befreien
das ist das Ergebnis
Symbol geworden ist dreht sich ja ganz
oft die Diskussion um diesen Panzer
dabei geht es mittlerweile eigentlich um
so viel mehr und ich freue mich dass Sie
sagen dass ihre Kollegen in Estland mit
Anerkennung darüber sprechen welchen Weg
Deutschland zurückgelegt hat aber ich
habe schon das Gefühl dass da einfach
viel Misstrauen herrscht dass man
eigentlich nur auf diesen Moment wartet
wann man wieder in die alte Spur zurück
kann also die die die der Weg den die
Deutschen jetzt zurückgelegt haben ist
wirklich nicht klein das ist auch eine
Überforderung auch eine öffentliche
Überforderung aber die Sorge dass sich
das ganz schnell wieder abwickeln lässt
dass man ganz schnell doch wieder diese
ausgestreckte vermeintlich ausgestreckte
Hand von Putin Geschäfte zu machen dass
man die doch ergreifend
zum Beispiel dass man wie Herr
Kretschmer von der CDU allerdings sagte
ja wenn der Krieg vorbei ist Verhandlung
dann machen wir auch wieder Geschäfte
mit russischem Gas das sollte sich
eigentlich wirklich in vielerlei
Hinsicht erledigt haben das heißt es ist
sogar richtig gefährlich zu sagen in
dieser Situation eröffnen wir jetzt Frau
fixel lagodinski eröffnen wir jetzt ein
Fenster der Diplomatie das ist ja genau
die Forderung wir sollten jetzt ist im
Grunde nutzen
die Gesprächsangebote zu machen diese
berühmten geheimdrähte die back-channels
gibt es ja ohnehin aber jetzt wäre der
Zeitpunkt für parallele Verhandlungen
Friedensinitiativen warum ist das so
gefährlich in ihren Augen da auch nur
darüber nachzudenken vorweg ich glaube
zuerst dabei muss man sagen dass
Verhandlungen und Diplomatie an sich ja
nicht schlecht sind das ist immer
sozusagen der Strom an der aufgestellt
wird alle sind belizistisch in den
westlichen Hauptstädten und wollen keine
Verhandlungen führen darum geht es nicht
Verhandlung und Diplomatie sind absolut
sinnvoll aber sie sind eben auch nicht
ohne Risiken Verhandlungen sind nicht an
sich einfach unschuldig die man führen
kann und nicht und ob es klappt oder
nicht bis dann egal wenn man jetzt in
Verhandlungen gehen würde zu den
Bedingungen die der russische Präsident
aufgestellt hat und das ist das die
Ukraine die Annexion diese versuchte
Annexion weil viele Teile
akzeptiert das würde bedeuten die
Kampfhandlungen würden das ist es was
russland will weil sie gerade auf der
Verliererseite sind und sie wollen mit
neuem Material sozusagen wieder ihre
Position stärken dann hat man ein halbes
Jahr Verhandlungen die zu nichts führen
in diesem Zeitraum stärkt Russland seine
Position und fängt im nächsten Frühjahr
wieder an und alles was ihr bisher
erreicht habt mit der Ukraine war
umsonst und damit ziehen wir diesen
Krieg noch länger hin als wir sowieso
schon da ist das ist nicht der Weg um
ihn schnell zu beenden und wir sehen
keinerlei Zugeständnis von der
russischen Seite es ist eher paradox das
sind eine Moment in dem die Ukraine
erfolgreich ist und tatsächlich
Territorien befreit diese Forderungen so
laut werden und der Grund dahinter ist
die nuklearangst das ist nicht anders zu
erklären und das ist auch sehr gut
nachvollziehbar aber zu verhandeln ohne
einen Plan zu haben wie es ausgehen soll
oder ohne eine Bereitschaft im
russischer Seite zu sehen das ist eben
auch ein Risiko weil wir dann ein
Russland haben was ich ermutigt fühlt
weil es etwas denkt es hat den Westen
gebrochen und das ist sozusagen auch
eine putinische KGB Mentalität der hat
seit dem Beginn des Krieges die
Ukrainerinnen und die Ukraine und auch
den besten immer wieder falsch gelesen
weil der Dach weil er denkt man muss nur
lange genug Druck ausüben dann werden
schon alle irgendwo irgendwann mit jeder
zerbrechen und das ist sozusagen der
Versuch warum er immer noch denkt dass
er diesen Krieg gewinnen kann weil er
glaubt dass er den besten an dieser
Position irgendwann haben wird dass der
Westen sagt Kiew jetzt mal langsam das
ist doch schon gut genug was wir jetzt
hier erreicht und das einmal ganz klar
zu sagen also diplomatische
Verhandlungen in dieser Form gibt es
niemanden in der SPD-Führung auch nicht
häufig oder sonstwien der diese Form von
von vielleicht nochmal was er gesagt hat
diplomatischen Verhandlungen nein ich
sage es auch wörtlich wenn sie es noch
mal hören wollen also er sagt 60 beruft
sich auf die Bürger und sagt 60 Prozent
der Bürger dieses Landes und er redet
genau von dieser Auseinandersetzung und
diesem Krieg wünschen nicht mehr
diplomatische Initiativen und er sagt
ich denke mal dass das auch an die
Adresse der Außenministerin es gibt in
meiner Parteiführung der möchte dass man
jetzt Friedensverhandlungen mit einem
Wladimir Putin führt der für den ganz
klar die Bedingungen dann sein wird dass
die ukraineteile ihres Territoriums
abgibt gut also dann fragen wir es wurde
ja verhandelt es wurde von
Istanbul in Belarus es traf sich die
ukrainische Seite und die russische
Seite die russischen entsandten waren
politisch marginale Figuren es war im
Prinzip eine große Show die die
Ausländer veranstaltet hat aber es wurde
gesprochen und die Punkte die auf dem
Tisch lagen zu denen die Ukraine bereits
eine Neutralität das betraf kein Leitung
des betraf sogar im Prinzip die
Territorien die jetzt teilweise
zurückerobert worden sind
es gab ein sehr wichtigen Punkt bei
diesen Verhandlungen und dieser Punkt
wird bedeutsam bleiben nämlich wie könnt
ihr uns garantieren dass wir nicht
wieder Opfer eines neuerlichen
russischen Überfalls werden und da ist
auch Deutschland gefragt da sind auch
die anderen Staaten gefragt wie können
wir sicherstellen dass wenn es
irgendwann mal tatsächlich zu diesem
Punkt kommt das nicht gekämpft wird
dass tatsächlich die Ukraine sich sicher
fühlen kann und eben dann als stabiler
Start weiterentwickeln kann und das ist
wahnsinnig schwer zu beantworten weil da
müssten ja
Sicherheitsgarantien von der NATO von
allen Ländern Europas total heikel total
heikartikel 5 sein dürfen nur ergänzen
ich glaube es gibt ein Vater Diplomatie
der tatsächlich wichtig ist und das ist
im Moment die Kommunikation mit China
mit Peking mit den Gesprächen die Scholz
und macron leider nicht zusammen aber
zumindest alleine in China führen sollen
weil es muss von allen Seiten nach
Moskau signalisiert signalisiert werden
dass wenn Sie mit dem Gedanken spielen
auch nur eine taktische Nuklearwaffe
einzusetzen das ist ein
Zivilisationsbruch wäre der dazu führt
dass ihr den Krieg nur noch schneller
verlieren das finde ich tatsächlich ein
extrem wichtigen Fahrt dort zu sprechen
aber genau wie erließbutter sagte das
ist im Moment gibt es gibt es dort keine
Perspektive und nach Istanbul ebenfalls
nicht wenn Sönke Neitzel ein Kollege
Historiker Kollege von ihnen Frau fix
sagt das wäre die Ukraine allein auf
Deutschland angewiesen hätte sie diesen
Krieg schon längst verloren dann sagt er
das und meint das an die Adresse des
Bundeskanzlers ich glaube er meint das
an die Adresse des ganzen deutschen
politischen sicherheitspolitischen
Establishments weil es ja auch so war
dass nach Kriegsausbruch die deutsche
Politik davon ausgegangen ist und den
Vorwurf kann man sozusagen also das war
so viele andere sind auch davon
ausgegangen dass die Ukraine einfach
keine Chance hat und deswegen auch
gezögert hat Waffen zu liefern weil die
weil die Vorstellung war dass Russland
einfach Durchm wird das war auch ein
Problem der militäranalyse weil viele
militäranalysten einfach Russland als zu
stark analysiert haben nach den
erfolgreichen nach der Glückssträhne die
bleibt mir Putin hier hatte aber auch
sehr gering und in Syrien genau
das ist absolut der Fall aber das
bedeutet wer sozusagen in dem Moment
rechtzeitig umgeschwenkt ist das sind
die USA die rechtzeitig umgeschwenkt
sind und hat das auch nicht vor und das
auch genau die das auch anders gesehen
haben aber die rechtzeitig umgeschwenkt
sind und die Waffen geliefert haben und
im Moment ist es gilt es auch weiterhin
so dass im Moment ohne die USA die
Ukraine verloren wäre also alle
Lieferungen die wir betreiben das ist
alles im Vergleich zu dem was die USA
macht nur Peanuts die Grünen haben einen
Herrler
einen super Schwenk gemacht und haben im
Grunde auch alle Pazifisten und alle
superpazifisten in ihrer Partei
offensichtlich
erfolgreich zum Schweigen gebracht oder
wo sind die das glaube ich nicht
vielleicht auch gesehen das war eine
demokratische Entscheidung da hat keiner
geschwiegen der sprechen wollte
ich glaube unser Partei ist einerseits
eine pazifistische Partei und dabei
bleibt es auch Frieden muss man auch
erhalten erkämpfen und verteidigen aber
unser Partei ist auch eine Partei der
Menschenrechte und auch eine
feministische Partei und wenn wir sehen
welche Verbrechen auf den besetzten
Gebieten stattfinden welche
generationalen Formen
die sind dieser Krieg annimmt da kann
eine Partei wie die Grünen auch nicht
schweigen und ich glaube es gibt auch
große Teile in anderen Parteien und
Katharina wir kennen uns ja auch sehr
gut ich bin mir sicher dass da auch eine
absoluter Konsens auch herrscht zwischen
den Teilen der SPD die das genauso sehen
gut aber es gibt eben auch Teile der
Politik oder eben sehr engagierte
Verteidiger der Ukraine die sagen es
gibt Kräfte innerhalb der SPD die
verhindern dass eben auch diese Ampel
mit einer anderen Strategie eben
beispielsweise die Zukunft der
militärischen Beteiligung der Ukraine
die Bundesregierung spielt spricht da
total mit einer Stimme und das ist ja
nun unsere Vertretung nach außen also
das ist das was nach außen die das Organ
was die Entscheidung
erklärt ja immer wieder warum er
bestimmte Dinge nicht liefern kann und
dass er glaubt dass das sehr klug ist
dass er sie nicht liefert und warum er
denkt dass es wichtig ist dass man auch
vorsichtig ist also da spricht ja eben
auch der Kanzler einer Regierung ich
frage sie noch mal sagen sie wie Herr
Klingbeil Frau barley dass wir unsere
Sicherheit in Europa nicht mehr mit
Russland sondern jetzt gegen Russland
neu denken müssen weil wir einen
strategischen Fehler gemacht natürlich
das ist der ganz offensichtlich ich
glaube ich weiß auch nicht wie man wie
man daran jetzt also wie man aus
irgendwelchen einer dieser Äußerungen da
dann Zweifel drin haben kann das ist es
ganz klar verteilt russland hat
sämtliche
ähm nicht nur internationalen Abkommen
sondern sämtliches Vertrauen gebrochen
was was in
Handelsbeziehungen und daraus folgende
minimalkonsense gesetzt wurde und dass
das eine Zeitenwende ist für alle
Beteiligten ist völlig klar und das mit
Russland auf absehbare Zeit überhaupt
keinen kein Konsens zu finden sein wird
auch nicht bei aber es ist ja so
interessant die Sprachen ja eben von
unserer Historie und dass diese Historie
uns abhielte eben auch militärisch zu
denken und dass unsere Soft Skills
Diplomatie nein nicht militärisch zu
denken sondern sozusagen eine
führungsstütze die alleinige Speerspitze
der Bewegung einzunehmen offensichtlich
hat der Herr Putin nicht das Gleiche
Bedürfnis sich an die Historie zu
erinnern sonst würde er nicht agieren
wie er agiert also sie schaffen mit
solchen Äußerungen natürlich auch
Argumentationslinien für Menschen die
sagen das machen wir jetzt nicht wir
können viel besser dipl Energie wir
haben vielleicht immer noch diesen super
Draht und mal gucken ob es in der
Umgebung von Wladimir Putin irgendetwas
gibt was wir da noch beeinflussen können
und das erste Mal seit ich mich
politisch in dieser Sache äußere dass
ich das mir das mir so eine
Interpretation
unterstellt wird also ich war immer bei
denjenigen die gesagt haben wir sollen
eher mehr Waffen liefern als weniger da
habe ich da habe ich nie irgendeinen
Zweifel dran gelassen also deswegen
dieses Zitat ist wie gesagt die Hälfte
eines doppelzitates da fühle ich mich
nur wirklich ausgesprochen und falsch
interpretiert kurz einhaken weil
Deutschland ist keine militärische
Führungsmacht ich zitiere wieder Frau
barley Deutschland ist keine
militärische Führungsmacht und sollte
das auch nicht werden wie gesagt nehmen
sie nehmen Sie bitte die die zwei Teile
zusammen mache ich gut
darf ich da einhalten es geht nämlich
ein eine Macht die die militärisch
dominant werden will wenn wir uns ein
Jahr zurückversetzen
in den Oktober November 2021 also der
russische Aufmarsch lief als die
diplomatischen Bemühungen anliefern und
auf Hochtouren waren das abzuwenden was
die amerikanischen britischen geheimen
Dienste damals schon gewarnt und gesagt
haben das passieren wird nämlich dieser
Krieg die Forderungen Russlands an
Europa an die NATO an die Vereinigten
Staaten nach nicht nur einem neuen Jahr
Alter sondern das was da gefordert wurde
die total der Rückbau der defakte
Rückbau der Osterweiterung die
schriftliche Garantie einer
Einflusssphäre die Art und Weise wie es
begründet wird durch putinhistorischen
Aufsatz im Juni letzten Jahres
ist ein Rekurs zu Karl Schmidt
völkerrechtliche großraumordnung und das
war das rational und die Begründung
die durch das Dritte Reich verändert
wurde um in den Hitler stalinpark
hineinzugehen und es hätte damals
eigentlich schon hätten die Alarmglocken
viel lauter schrillen müssen als sie es
getan haben nur gesagt getan das Problem
ist wir haben jetzt nicht die Zeit
selbst Therapie zu spielen natürlich ist
die zeitenwände für Deutschland ein
gewaltiger Schritt da wo man stand das
Problem ist die Geschichte dreht sich
viel schneller als wir uns das in
unseren innerparteilichenstreitereien
erlauben können und das zweite Problem
ist wir haben auch nicht nur ein
gespaltenes Europa wir haben eine
zunehmende gespaltene USA und wir können
uns nicht mehr so tief drauf verlassen
dass die Amerikaner immer die Führung
ausüben werden die sie es gemacht haben
in der Stärke in der Kraft in der sie
das gemacht haben spielen sie auf auch
jetzt die Mitte also diese
sondern auch
es gibt auch in der amerikanischen
Regierung genau dasselbe was ich bei uns
tut ein
also ein echter dezent ein Lizenz
zwischen ver bedingungs Außenminister in
den USA zwischen verteidigungs-
die die plöckners in Washington heißen
Sullivan und auch dort gibt es enorme
Streitereien wie weit man gehen darf
kann soll was man liefern kann und so
weiter und in dieser Situation müssen
wir müssen wir wenn wir verhindern
wollen dass Russland die dominante
Militärmacht in Europa wird und über die
Kraft seiner militärischen Dominanz die
Ordnung Europas diktieren wird müssen
wir schauen dass es diesen Krieg
verliert und da können wir diese
Befindlichkeiten ob jetzt ein System
defensiv ist oder offensiv ist und ob es
uns leichter fällt a zu liefern oder B
zu liefern diese Dinge müssen wir hinter
uns lassen